is the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration smarter than a fifth
grader I wouldn't bet on it do you stop
it Oh oh hello didn't see you there
folks gotta tell you this month NOAA is
going to release its annual predicted
forecasts for Atlantic hurricanes
there's only one problem in the last
seven years this same pivotal agency
largely responsible for global warming
alarmism has only got its predictions
right a whopping two times
now I know last year Noah beat national
centers trained chimp dr. Han simian by
finally getting a forecast right but he
wasn't exactly our top banana yeah let's
see how they do against rookie and
experts with opposable thumbs
meet fifth-graders kateandchris
both graduated magna [ __ ] Mladic from
goddard tiny tot school Chris here's the
best song after Santa in the myth of
carbon free flight and came here penned
the prize-winning it's not easy being
green the unauthorized Kermit the Frog
biography chronicling the fall of grace
from America's favorite puppet to
environmental zealot so kateandchris
according to research how many
hurricanes will be this year 3 Wow
where'd you get those numbers what cards
do you have 3 n 8
you can argue with science
besides their methods are statistically
just as effective as Noah's maybe more
how do we know we happen to have the
actual numbers that Noah released just
last week say mr. Noah
how many hurricanes would that be this
year say that sounds like a pretty
widespread yeah that's really scientific
oh you say shenanigans I say perfect
microcosm of government efficiency
spilly federal government